Let's start with a brief overview of Software
Defined Networking, or SDN. We'll first start by
defining SDN, and in particular we'll talk about
what is a Software Defined Network, then well
talk about what are the advantages of SDN
over a conventional network architecture. We'll overview the
history of SDN, the infrastructure that supports it,
in particular how SDNs are designed and built and
the applications of SDN. Specifically, what they can
be used for and how they can be
used to simplify various network management tasks. Perhaps
the best way to understand what an SDN
is Is to compare it to the behavior
of today's networks. Today's networks have two functions.
The first is the Data Plane, whose task
it is to forward packets to their ultimate destination.
But in order for the Data Plane to work,
we also need a way of computing the state
that each of these routers has that allows the
routers to make the right decision in forwarding traffic to
the destination. The state that lives in each of
these routers that allows the routers to make these
decisions about how to forward packets are called routing
tables. It's the job of the network's Control Plane to
compute these routing tables. In conventional networks, the Control
and Data Plane both run on the routers that are distributed across the network.
In an SDN, the Control Plane runs in a logically centralized controller.
Additionally, the controller typically controls multiple
routers across the network and often,
the control program exerts control over all
the routers in the network, thus facilitating network-wide
control. These two characteristics are the defining
features of a Software Defined Network. The separation
of data and control allows a network
operator to build a network with commodity devices,
where the control, resides in a separate control
program. This re-factoring allows us to move from
a network where devices are vertically
integrated making it very tough to innovate
to a network where the devices have open interfaces that can be controlled by
software. Thus, allowing for much more
rapid innovation. Let's survey a brief history
of SDN. Previous to 2004, configuration was
distributed, leading to buggy and unpredictable behavior.
Around 2004, we had the idea to control the network from
a logically centralized high level program. That logically centralized
controller focused on the border gateway protocol, and was called the routing
control platform, or RCP. In 2005, researchers
generalized the notion of the RCP for different planes. The decision
plane which computed the forwarding state for
devices in the network, the Data Plane,
which forwarded traffic based on decisions made
by the decision plane. And the dissemination and
discovery planes, which provide the decision plane
the information that it needs to compute
the forwarding state, which ultimately gets pushed
to the data plane. Around 2008, these concepts
effectively hit the mainstream, through a
product called OpenFlow. OpenFlow's intellectual roots are
with the RCP and 4D. But OpenFlow
has made practical when merchant silicon vendors
open their APIs, so that switch chipsets
could be controlled from software. So suddenly
there was an emergence of cheap switches that were build based on open chip
sets that could be controlled from
software. This development effectively allowed us
to decouple the control plane and
the data plane in commodity switching hardware.